hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Sheree
and we're gonna watch some movie clips
of Sin City - a dame to kill for yeah
there's a lot of movie clips out there
are there see too much before the movie
comes in well there's like 30 second
clips it's a whole minute if there are
three of them that's a whole minute I
already have seen the two [ __ ]
searched forever for like all the clips
okay yeah I I feel this need to satisfy
you know cuz don't black people have
been requesting and I feel this urge to
you know satisfy the subscribers hey you
know cuz you know what happens when like
I could watch six clips but if I didn't
watch clip number seven they're gonna
get mad at me J Ryan I mean I just I
think you gotta calm down a little bit
like it's give and take you know like
yeah you do want for you one for them
for you one for them and everybody's
happy by the end of the day okay okay I
hope that works with you guys I hope I
hope we can come to an agreement here
yeah because they keep using a bunch of
homosexuals because you can slurs
against a pouch I mean I think this has
gotten a little too soon as that's the
case like cuz also it like you can't
just be a slave otherwise you'll hate
what you do and that's not cool
that's true that's so true know you give
good advice check there's gotta be a way
to compromise let it go let it go smack
oh ho
smack oh ho as this movie gets closer to
its release date I get a little bit
nervous I mean don't get me wrong the
first time I saw the trailer I was like
[ __ ] ready to jizz everywhere you know
I've been nervous since the day they
announced this was heaven I'm looking at
the footage and I'm like it looks like
Sin City yes but I remember Rodriguez a
machete kills I'm like this looks like
machete yeah it was like it's a little
too much of machete and I'm like I'm
worried he's just gonna go like too
overboard with it I remember when the
first machete came out you weren't like
super amped about it no no ideally not
cuz Sin City is a movie we saw together
and like I loved that movie with machete
it's a little less
of an impact on because it's like I like
the first machine and there's more
freedom to it you know he's doing this
Basin he has to keep it in the world
with the comics yeah I mean they would
upset fans if he was like you know the
first one how we really honor the story
I'm gonna take complete creative freedom
it's in City I like love that movie so
like this mistakes are high plus you
know the spirit didn't go so well and
for better or worse Robert Rodriguez can
kind of do whatever he wants and that
kind of power can sink ships I just hope
it I just hope it's a good time I do do
that's all I really care I just want it
to be good man I was really afraid
yeah okay let's start the night off
shall we
let's start off with [ __ ] Gale Gale
here we go Gale girl
give me like pound listen this doesn't
look like the brightest a video
damn I mean so we know that Dwight is
gonna get hurt we know that there will
be blood spill from Dwight and that Gail
is gonna be there to help him out again
yeah so it's keeping the essence of Part
1 still good clip good clip
I'm anxious alright with that clip
because all that clip confirms is that
there are characters in the movie yeah
and Gail's tits look a lot bigger for
some reason huge yeah honestly I'm not
the biggest fan of rosario dawson as an
actress though like during things i've
heard her she's really good in trance
i'm going off with a few rolling
actually seen how example but even as
Gail I never fully believed her yeah
there's a heightened universe well yeah
I don't believe a lot of people in this
universe think but Gail's one of them
I'm like I just don't buy this actress
like I like the character more than I
like the performance okay change your
[ __ ] opinion I'm sorry
she's not even trying
oh yeah that's hot
but oh he's attracted to a girl looking
like really kill people for some reason
that's my type man murderer
yeah someone who can protect me I'm not
liking the presence of this new me hell
as much yeah Devin there seems to be a
lack of life in her a little bit Devin
ioki sir very much had a lot in her face
she's just a baby
yeah cuz like she had this imposing
presence where she could snap at any
moment but even snapping is graceful
like there's she had a lot of presence
yeah yeah from this little clip I don't
know I'm not feeling her quite as much
but maybe maybe it takes a whole film
yeah maybe but just like the way she was
moving is like everything about her just
the body language in the resonators good
last move was cool [ __ ] helicopters
worth it yeah that was cool but that's a
bet that's what the move is called
that's the one thing I'm afraid of the
movies like these it's not pushing the
limit too hard but I think this is a
prequel at least the the Dwight story is
a prequel to the one we got in the first
in City so yeah cuz it's before he got
his face change oh so the Dwight that we
saw was the face change
yeah I thought Dwight change his face to
look like no the Josh Brolin one no this
is before that that would make sense
yeah how making you work his back
exactly when in that story he says he's
describing himself and he says you know
like a two-bit convict with a new face
or whatever he says something about
having a new face in reference to
himself so oh okay we already had but
I'm always a little weary when they go
back in time and then give characters
more abilities than they had when you
see them later on yeah telling Legolas
in Lord of the Rings in in The Hobbit
too is like I've seen you in a future
and you don't move quite that gracefully
kind of like every Jedi and the Star
Wars prequels yeah why are you all
crazier now yeah this doesn't seem to
have broken that but I'm a little afraid
they might mmm-hmm but yeah at least
from that little little scene I'm not
feeling her as much as I know her
presence just doesn't look as
intimidating
let's still do stuff with her I was
wondering I'm glad you clarified I would
like her I would like to be doing her
and have her have a sort of against my
throat the whole time that would be hot
I'd be like dirty little me oh oh I have
to give you have to give alright this
one's called trespassing
whoa
something about the way these clips are
edited seems weird yeah it's like kind
of choppy and very light
well there's moments don't seem to be
hitting yeah when we watch the meal clip
it I couldn't help but think like I bet
that's gory or in the actual movie but
even like in the [ __ ] arm which would
affect the editing because they probably
cut out shots or cut downs yeah even
with the Gael clip it was like one
second he says Gael like the editing of
it was just so like off to me these are
probably damn Berlin I hope so yeah
brain but then again also I mean it
could just take you know whole movie too
or at least you know slipping into a
movie from the beginning to understand
what the flow of the dialogue or the
flow of the editing is yeah that's true
but yeah from these clips it does look a
little bit ah yeah it's like it's it's
it looks a little bit like what I'm
fearing it's gonna be like really
fast-paced Rodriguez craziness yeah
rather than like I loved what he did
with the first one but I'm let's see
what it takes it seems like he's putting
into hyperdrive but these are all one
type of clips so far and I like the I
like the cool see in the history between
[ __ ] black guy and Mickey Rourke oh
yeah when I was worried lost his eye
first clip I've seen with Dennis
Haysbert instead of Michael Clarke
Duncan I could see why they got him I
mean it's like they don't look the same
but the voices sound similar yeah in
that clip you know it's like they have a
similar present yeah absolutely
absolutely let's move on alright Redbank
clip Marv kills
marv Shetty Marchetti haha
yes
good Marv's pissed off got some that
clip was more reassuring for me yeah I'm
like I like it the way the pacing is
going I like the tone the violence looks
cool doesn't look like it's creative a
little bit more out there but just
enough well that's the thing that is
like that's the red band trailer or the
red band clip so it seems like they
certainly cut that one town less yeah
yeah yeah definitely you know I I quite
enjoyed that clip I did too I don't know
how much more figures into damn to kill
floors like I only read a part of that
book and I just remember him and Dwight
like bumping into each other
why are you friendly I don't think it's
just solely based off a day me kill for
it it's not that's why I'm saying I'm
wondering if they did of another like
original story with Mickey with Marv
certain stuff is an adaptation of some
of the books and stories and then other
stuff is original oh cool and that's on
the one hand cool but on the other hand
I'm kind of worried yeah yeah yeah did
they get william monahan
like time to script I that's what you
told me yeah man I'm malleable him on
hands writing he's looking to the
departed [ __ ] what hotted [ __ ] homo
all right this one's called
crazy hours booth
and this is the sequel right yeah I can
tuck my hair
wait mark still alive he does show up at
the end of a Nancy story right because
even the first Sin City is not in
chronological order because mark shows
up later on in the movie after his
story's already oh yeah yeah okay sorry
the timelines getting me confused
the timing is very confusing yeah
because this is Nancy's story it's a
Mars story takes place like after yeah
okay yeah all right or at least the
first Mars story
why should have stitches she's cut
herself I don't know I don't know how
how much doctors could cuz I know
they've released that image already but
um yeah I don't know maybe she cut her
face up just pointlessly it to look
crazy I would imagine that's the kind of
thing they'll explain okay
I hope I don't think they can do
something like that without at least
being like this is what happens Jessica
Alba looks like Jessica Alba
performance is Jessica Alba ask you'll
have two lines I mean that's enough to
tell this is I mean the only thing I'm
really worried about here is is this
stuff because I really hope that it
makes sense and it's very natural to
have all these characters back who were
gone from the first one cuz I really
don't want them to shoehorn stuff in but
there is an overwhelming urge to do so
understandably yeah people love Hartigan
and they loved Marv and they loved these
guys the horse of course yeah I'm a
little afraid I just don't know how to
feel right now
it's like worrying me a little bit like
like it looks it looks like it's okay
but it's not you know sometimes you
watch a movie clip and you're like yeah
this is gonna be good this is not doing
that for me it is like um well yeah this
doesn't look bad but I'm a little bit
worried yeah well cause II this is why
this is why I don't tend to want to
check out movie clips just because you
start thinking you start overthinking
and it's like on the one hand I don't
know I've seen a snippet in this movie
and I'm feeling a certain way about it
you know but on the other hand it's only
like you know 45 seconds to a minutes
worth of yeah you know a long film so
it's like sometimes I don't feel like
it's fair necessarily to out-of-context
rip apart these little scenes that's
true that's true cuz I don't want to
like infect my mind with that
expectation then go in
you know of course I am a little worried
if yeah nobody's killing anybody I mean
that's pretty cool that was cool is that
Ellie Kemper on the bed I think so yeah
yeah Dwight looks like a badass it looks
like a different version of Dwight for
sure it's not button I don't mean that
just physically look he liked it seems
like it's gonna be a different portrayal
yeah one it seems like since its earlier
on it's like oh maybe this is cool or
like maybe he was a little more
moralistic yeah until whatever happened
and then the Sin City we see he's a
little more willing to hear this guy I
don't know again this is why I'm afraid
to watch these clips and draw draw
conclusions but it looks like Josh
Brolin's gonna be pretty bouncing you
know it's Josh Brolin Josh I mean any
Josh Brolin is good despite how bad a
movie is and he will be good all right
next clip looks like trouble oh-oh it
does oh it's him
okay yeah are you still really promoting
the action yeah like it seems to be I
hope the movie is not just that cuz you
know like well Mason City great is the
film noir yeah you know like there's not
really like a there's action for sure
it's one of the genres but there's not
like a [ __ ] ton of action yeah I mean I
think maybe that's just a byproduct of
the times it's like it's been away it's
been since 2005 since we had the last
movie maybe they're like yeah maybe
that's probably what I feel like these
clips is probably just the clips but I
feel like that's the sense we're not
getting film noir yeah exactly
I feel like that's lacking I mean it's
like what part of a Mason City so cool
is like finding out why these guys we're
kicking ass yeah we're gonna do it like
not just the fact that they did it yeah
so I just want that film no more spirit
still there as if it's there then that's
all I have I'm sure be I feel like just
a Gordon Levitt would bring that for
sure yeah see those things like on the
one hand I'm kind of happy that these
clips just kind of show nothing because
like all the story stuff will be a
surprise but when I get excited if I was
like excited about seeing a Sin City
clip like what I would be excited for is
hearing the internal narrations yeah
seeing the world that they're exactly
underbelly yeah watching them just exist
in the space you know talking to each
other that Frank Miller dialogue
yes something tells me he's like it
feels like they're filming the Sin City
world I don't feel like they're backed
into being immersed in the Sin City
world that's see that's what I that's
what I hope is just not coming through
because the main character of all these
clips has been killing people well guys
thanks for recommending all those
[ __ ] clips if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects it's great stuff here
enjoy well youtubers ask questions at
the end of their videos
so since we did sin city a dame to kill
for hey do you think [ __ ] or sex are
more personal because women have told me
that they only blow guys if they're in a
relationship but they'll still have sex
yeah tell me your opinion personally I
have a view sex is more personal but
apparently it's a bigger dick sucked is
not it's more personal and intimate
whatever is such a [ __ ] okay hey you
how many girls have told me that no
three axel Ramirez he wants a shout-out
and he said please good good
next step in a shout-out is to say the
word please says really yeah like that's
great it's like politeness is wonderful
dude of course of course please thank
you for asking
Thank You axle Ramirez he is the Spanish
version of Axl Rose I have just thinking
that Axl Ramirez and in the club part at
Guns and Roses si yep he's Mexican
gangster good for you Axl you stay with
that guitar Wayne oh he's the singer
actually my bad alright I'm gonna get a
lot of heat for that now sorry you could
do a 15-minute video thanks laughs and
you get one thing wrong everyone's gonna
go sky there's no [ __ ] Doug Yacht notice
me Ryan give me a shout-out Ryan you
know you want to
or is it right lot oh is it done a lot
okay Ryan Ryan now you sound like
someone who would suck my dick
Alex I mean I didn't mean to do it that
way it very theatrical hi Ryan
I mean hi Doug Doug Doug Doug Glatt Jian
if it's if it's just a really far away L
and the dot is blending I'm gonna do
some spoken word for you Doug okay I go
on the channel look at the panel and who
do I see a guy named Doug who I want to
give a hug and I feel like that I'm
rolling up in a rug and I feel like I
got a slug in my head to my spoken word
is not freestyle it is an artistic form
we can do it over music I know you can
but every time I watch spoken word they
don't
usually on stage there's an open mic
night in a coffee shop somewhere it's
exactly what I've seen is that the
coffee bean
I just spoken so funny depending on what
the topic is they all sound the same the
world
well that's [ __ ] up but there's beauty
seven horror fan your neighbor is hot I
would all I would love a shout out my
neighbor is Marie I don't think she's
hot I mean that's your opinion
I mean she's pretty there are actresses
that people think are that's not true
100 percent of people agree that meg
Ryan is the hottest girl of all time
I don't know mmm NATO's okay no Jennifer
Lawrence yeah it's like I understand
like I on a logical level like yeah
she's super attractive but for a
personal level I I'm more attracted to
Lawrence's personality than I am like
her looks physically I mean she's pretty
and all I just don't feel like we get
you know we we mesh well the end of the
day as a couple we could be good friends
though okay
she's a big fan of the show in between
takes
she's on her iPhone just looking at the
real respect to a trailer accident
silver linings playbook too but seven
horror fan
yeah Murray school and you do get a show
we'll give you a shout okay horror fan I
love horror movies go you he does love
horror movies I do he was gonna do it
playlist one's called Jerry's horror
corner I still mind now that they're
morning I was gonna do one called Ryan's
[ __ ] corner let's see which one takes
out but it deserves a Fitz boat no no we
should piss mom if it's not the seven
horror fan that's the same thing legal
process we piss won't do the same thing
it's on video with though when we get
excited about a movie people go someone
who's like fake reaction a fake reaction
and if you're not excited boring
reaction okay here's the thing that like
when I watch traitors in the theater I'm
not the way I am when I'm watch
[ __ ] computer with a friend you know
no you haven't been I haven't lately
there was a moment where I've been like
you've done a lot of these oh [ __ ] we
went to theaters for something not the
past couple times but like we went to
the theaters for something recently and
you were sitting like up in your chair
like like it was the couch and like
something crazy Avenue like oh yeah
because I'm watching them at home with
it on the computer you you do do that
yeah at least I do you know yeah so I
get really excited about it and I don't
know I guess getting comfortable doing
it in front of four people that's made
me just feel comfortable doing it in the
theater yeah because I you just express
what's going on inside of me all over
the crowd